في صحراء اريزونا تجرى واحده من اكثر
معارك انتخابات التجديد النصفي تنافسيه
على منصب الحاكم بين الجمهوريه كاريك
والديمقراطيه كيتي هوبز وبينهما الكثير من
الاستقطاب
هي نجمه الحزب الجمهوري الجديده اختارها
ترامب بنفسه لخوض السباق وتتبنى خطابه
بتزوير انتخابات عام 2020 بكل قوه
قناه السعيده
[تصفيق]
اذا قرر خوض سباق عام 2014
[موسيقى]
السباق يحمل صراعا اخر داخل الحزب الاحمر
النائبه الجمهوريه التي تشارك في تحقيقات
اقتحام الكبتل وتسببت ترامب في خسارتها
الانتخابات التمهيديه لهذا السبب تدعمه
ايضا يدعمها النائب الجمهوري ادم كنزنجر
الذي يشارك في تحقيقات الكابيتل ووفر على
نفسه اهانه خساره الانتخابات التمهيديه
باعلانه عدم الترشح مجددا
استطلاعات الراي لم تحسمه هويه الفائز في
سباق حاكم اريزونا افضليه بسيطه للغايه
للمرشحه الجمهوريه تدعمه انتقادات للمرشحه
الديمقراطيه التي ترفض اجراء مناظره ويؤكد
معارضها انها خائفه من احراج علني